With the
Jedi once numbered in the thousands,
what's left of a scattered, frightened
and mostly beaten
and in hiding or poorly trained children
like yourself.
Welcome back everyone
This is the way. The Mandalorian
just debuted
Grand Admiral Thrawn
and the Empire's Shadow Council
and introduce a bunch of teasers
for their Thrawn movie
based on heir to the Empire
and the original Thrawn book trilogy
from the nineties.
In a big part of that is Thrawn interest
in the force in the Jedi.
Like the big four sensitive characters
in the show like Luke Skywalker,
Grogu's, Ahsoka.
So we'll explain why he wants them so bad
and how his plans
for the Jedi of the Force
users are so different
from what Moff Gideon's plans for Grogu
and all the others were, as well as
the other members of the Shadow Council.
Because the next big part of the story,
The Mandalorian Season four, the Thrawn
movie,
The Ahsoka series, is all about explaining
all the different members
of the Shadow Council
and how they have competing ideas about
what they should use All the Jedi for.
Grand Admiral
Thrawn is missing from your delegation.
Our one hope for success relies upon
the secrecy of his return, but
Thrawn is their de facto leader right now.
He's more important
than all the other Imperials
in Thrawn himself
doesn't really care that much
about the other members
of the Shadow Council.
He kind of thinks of them as squabbling
children.
Just tools to be used in the execution
of his grand plans for the galaxy.
So if you're new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
The Mandalorian Season
three finale is happening this week.
Also be doing videos for the Ahsoka series.
Next. It's only the beginning.
During the recent episodes
of The Mandalorian,
Thrawn was mentioned by the Shadow Council
with some teasers for his character,
and they teased the idea
that Moff Gideon also hates him.
Like this whole Thrawn versus Moff Gideon
competing plan.
Each one thinks themselves
the leaders of the Shadow Council
like Moff Gideon wants to replace Thrawn
as their de facto leader.
They implied that since the events
of Return of the Jedi up to this point,
Thrawn has been the de facto
leader of the Shadow Council,
but he barely cares
about the other members
enough to show up for their regular galaxy
wide Skype meetings.
Like that's how little he cares
about the rest of the Shadow Council.
He views himself as the next de facto
face of the Empire
after the death of the Emperor,
the official heir to the Empire.
As the title of the book
in the Thrawn trilogy, Theron's return
as heir to the Empire.
He has his own grand plan for the Galaxy.
The Jedi are a huge part of those plans.
He wants Grogu Luke Skywalker, Ahsoka,
Ezra Bridger, The Other Jedi.
Just as much as Moff Gideon wanted them,
but for completely different reasons.
Moff Gideon
just confirmed all of our theories.
His whole plan for them was to combine
the greatest aspects of the Mandalorians
their beskar metal weapons, armor
with grogu
whose connection to the force is ultra
high.
Medic Florian Count and Dr.
Pershing's cloning technology to
combine all the greatest aspects of them
to create the ultimate next generation
dark trooper clones that would be force
sensitive and nearly indestructible.
Every society has something to offer
the clones, the Jedi,
and even the Mandalorians.
He planned to use those new dark troopers
to dominate the galaxy
with an unbeatable army.
Thrawn also wants to control the galaxy
like he wants a strong army.
Yes, it's important to him, but he doesn't
care as much about grafting Grogu
Luke Skywalker.
Jedi Force
sensitive DNA into his own clone Army.
The reason he cares about the Jedi
is because he sees their value
as much, much greater
than what Moff Gideon sees in them.
There are a lot of clues for his plans
for the force
during Star Wars
rebels during the Ahsoka trailer.
When you see him start to talk more
and more about the power of the Jedi
and how he felt like they died out
because they had a lack of vision
of how to use their power.
With the Jedi
one's numbered in the thousands
what's left of a scattered, frightened,
mostly beaten and in hiding
or poorly trained children like yourself.
I must admit
the mysteries of the force on Nakatomi.
But for all those abilities,
all the power,
the Jedi lacked the vision
for how to wield it.
When he's telling Ezra Bridger
that he thinks the Jedi will do this
grand cosmic power, but lacked the vision
to know what to actually do with it.
He's talking about the World
between Worlds,
which was obviously a big plot point
during Star Wars rebels in
Sounds like it's going to be a big plot
point during the Ahsoka series
and heading into the heir to the Empire
Thrawn movie, The World Between Worlds
was a place that Dave Filoni created
during Star Wars Rebels.
It was new to the canon during rebels
meant to be a nexus in the force
connected to all points in time and space,
kind of like a pocket dimension
made up of pure force energy.
A space kind of like the mortis realm
where the father, the son,
and the daughter force beings existed.
When Ezra Bridger was able to enter
the world between worlds to a point,
a soldier from earlier in the timeline
when she was fighting Darth Vader
in the Sith Temple.
Great scene.
She also saw the Force Owl,
which is the daughter's aspect.
Like the daughter itself
was actually looking at her
while they were in the world
between worlds.
So the space is also somewhat connected
to the mortis realm
and a big part of the mortis realm,
as well as the world between worlds,
is that just anybody can't walk into it
like you can't find the door.
Even very powerful Jedi
haven't been able to fight it in the past.
Dave Filoni already said that
the associates series
is like an honorary sequel to Star Wars
Rebels, so everything that happened
during Rebels is still canon
in live action.
Now in the timeline will drive
some of the events of the Ahsoka
series, the Thrawn movie.
What's happening with Thrawn story
just in general.
In this part of the timeline,
before Ezra Bridger used the Pergolas
and space wells
we just saw in The Mandalorian
the Ahsoka trailer to take Thrawn
the Seventh Fleet into the unknown
regions.
Thrawn had been collecting Jedi
and Sith artifacts.
They showed his office
a lot during rebels.
In the background
you can see the ysalamiri on his mural here.
Those were the lizards
from the original heir
to the Empire Thrawn trilogy of books
that had the natural ability
to create force
canceling area of effects around a person.
So he'd use them to basically cancel out
all digitized powers
when he was interacting with them.
You could see that
he has a Jedi Temple guardian helmet here.
He's been studying
the Mortes gods, the father, the son,
the daughter, as well as the mortis realm
in the world between worlds.
That's where the mural was found at
the entrance to the world between worlds.
So he's had these ideas about how to use
the world between worlds for a long time,
even though at this point in the timeline,
when we're seeing this scene,
the emperor was still alive
because it was before Return of the Jedi.
So the emperor had his own interest
in controlling the world between worlds.
But Thrawn always hated the Emperor.
That's still Khan,
and had his own plans for the galaxy.
So during present day, while the Emperor's
spirit is waylaid in limbo,
so to speak, Thrawn has the opportunity
to pursue his own true goals.
As far as Dave Filoni explained
during Star Wars Rebels, only
the light side, Jedi or neutral characters
like the Bindu in the Force
can enter the world between worlds.
As far as we know, the Sith can't enter,
and this actually plays into
what's happening during the Ahsoka series.
I'll explain in a second
because there's a difference between pure
Sith characters or other Jedi.
The just bend a little bit dark
but aren't true Dark Sith.
The Bending is a good example of this
just because he wields both the dark side
and the light side.
So he is technically true neutral.
So in order for someone
who is not for sensitive or for a Sith,
like a pure evil
Sith to enter the world between worlds,
they'd have to get a light side Jedi
or someone neutral
like the Ben do to actually physically
take them into the world
between worlds like Luke Skywalker.
Ahsoka Grogu
Ezra Bridger in Thrawn
wants to use the world
between worlds to bring his own idea
of order to the galaxy,
like his idea for peace with the true goal
of protecting his people.
The Chase, which has been his goal
this whole time.
Once the Emperor learned
of their existence in the unknown regions,
Thrawn actually surrendered to the Emperor
under the pretense that he would serve him
if he left the ships alone.
The ships were also threatened by other
major races in the unknown regions.
The risk are a good example
that in the more recent Thrawn stories,
if you're a big fan of the Thrawn books,
so if you're trying
to bring order to the galaxy,
the world between worlds
is the ultimate way to accomplish that.
The most efficient way possible.
Because using it, you could send armies
anywhere in time and space instantly.
Star Wars meets time travel.
You could put down rebellions,
any kind of pirates, chaos, war
like species anywhere in the galaxy
before they actually happened.
The ultimate order brought to the galaxy.
But Thrawn can't gain access to this place
without Grogu's help.
Luke Skywalker, Ahsoka Ezra Bridger.
Someone would actually have to
take him in there
and then continue to open the barrier
when he wanted to send armies in so
he'd have to have a Jedi working with him.
He can't simply pull a Moff Gideon
and dissect them for their DNA.
Just having Jedi Edina
High medical ranking
doesn't guarantee you'll be able to enter
the world between worlds.
The cosmic force,
the living force have to let you in.
Which is one of the reasons why,
just in the history of the galaxy itself,
the history of the Jedi in the Sith,
very few people, if any, had ever been
able to enter the world between worlds.
It was meant to be a legend in the force
passed down for many thousands of years.
When Ezra Bridger entered it,
it was meant to be a huge deal,
like the first time
it happened in recorded history.
As far as people knew.
It's the same thing
with Alnwick and Skywalker, Obi-Wan Kenobi
and Ahsoka entering the mortis realm
like one of the first times
that had ever happened
that people knew of because the force
itself, like the cosmic force,
the living force, allowed them to enter.
This is why the ember other ancient Sith
haven't been able to enter it before now.
And as Thrawn told Ezra Bridger,
this is Canon to
he never wanted to kill anyone,
least of all the Jedi.
That was never his goal.
Thrawn Superpower is his mind.
He's the greatest military commander
in the history of the galaxy,
so all of his plans are superior to every
other person's plan of the galaxy.
So of course he'd have a better idea
to manage the galaxy
than the New Republic,
which they've shown to be
pretty ineffectual and actually pretty bad
during the Mandalorian Season three.
They really want to drag the New Republic
in the mud during season three here.
So Thrawn has been trying to get his hands
on any Jedi that he can't
and convince them his way of thought
is the superior way for the galaxy,
which is one of the main reasons
why in the Ahsoka trailer those new Dark
Jedi Balance School insinuated
are in league with Thrawn
because we're talking about
heir to the Empire, the original Thrawn
trilogy, Easter Eggs and references.
Balan Skull is meant to be the stand in
for the jurors.
Kibo, a character
in the original Thrawn trilogy,
The Jedi Master, that
he forms an agreement with.
Neither one kind of likes each other
in the way race.
Stephenson talked about Theron's character
and his character
during the Ahsoka series.
It sounds like that
will continue to be true in present day
with these versions of the characters
like Balan, Skull is working with him
only out of necessity,
not because he enjoys Theron's company
or anything like that.
So just to be clear,
Thrawn does want Grogu
to Luke Skywalker, Ahsoka,
all those force sensitive characters,
but not because he wants to kill them
or he wants to get rid of them
or anything like that.
He wants to convince them
that his path forward
for the galaxy is the best path
and for them to help him.
That's why during the Ahsoka trailer,
it seems like Balan school
is fighting a soldier
in a Jedi temple with symbols around him
That makes it seem
like they're in the world between worlds.
Oh, they're trying to enter the world
between worlds.
We'll get a bunch more teasers
as we get more footage
for the Ahsoka series
in The Mandalorian sort of teases out
what's happening during season four
and how this is all connected
to what Thrawn is doing.
Also doing more videos about that
specifically
when they start revealing more things.
If you have any big questions
about what's going on with the characters
or any of the characters in general,
just write them below in the comments.
I've got a bunch of bonus videos
that I'm working on.
My Full Mandalorian Season
three Episode eight Finale Video.
We'll post next.
Be sure to enable alerts on my channels
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for that video
and click here for my brand
new Ahsoka trailer with a bunch of footage
that they didn't release online.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.